today's question this is a really
interesting question and I think it
comes down to the genre spaces that
exist or rather don't exist across
different media horror as a genre of
play be it stage radio or screen is a
well-established genre and well explored
in fact the very notion of a scary story
is fairly pervasive in our society the
idea of scary music on the other hand
well even just saying it out loud feels
somewhat absurd for whatever complicated
reasons song isn't a well accepted
medium for delivery of a scary story
this is in no small part why Evil Dead
the musical is ultimately a comedy and
why people find Sweeney Todd's tone to
be you know weird and even those are
examples where song is being mixed with
stage and screen mediums where horror is
already well accepted at the same time
though this isn't limited to horror if I
said oh it's an action album that sounds
like nonsense even if an album was
nothing but a tea style cinematic rock
anthems we still wouldn't describe it as
an action album at best it would seem
like a cute way of describing something
a little unconventional
at the same time we would find it weird
to describe a movie as say punk rock or
folk pop do you know is a very folk pop
movie it sounds weird but you kind to
get it even then it's really only
helpful if you've already seen Juno and
are in on the joke and can go oh yeah I
see what you're saying
cute it doesn't say anything about
content or structure only tone so to
loop back to your specific example I
would say there's an added element that
audiences don't generally conceptualize
metal as a storytelling genre of music
they wouldn't expect it to generate
something like one tin soldier or
nautical disaster despite the fairly
mainstream evidence to the contrary like
Metallica's one when you stack
moralizing on top of that it's a lot
easier to frame the music as being
purely the expression of individual
intent and not a storytelling narrative
device and this perception is not really
helped by the fact that the vocals in a
lot of metal and its various subgenres
are frankly unintelligible which lends
some weight to the idea that you know
messages are being hidden in the music
even if that idea is kind of balderdash
and nonsense
bottom line audiences don't
think about music as a way to tell a
horror story so thanks that's a great
question there's a lot more to think
about in there like why do John Roos
develop differently across different
mediums you can let me know what you
think in the comments and as always if
you've got a question you can submit it
through ask fm or Twitter now go and
peace my children in the name of like
share and subscribe
amen